thank everybody i'm going to talk today
about the
uh confederated salish kootenai tribe
uh which i offered as cskt
tribes uh compact with the state of
montana um to which the us government
was also party um this compact kind of
evolved over the course of a couple of a
few decades and actually just started to
be implemented this year so we'll we'll
talk about how they got there
um just to start this is montana um
these are the various water basins in
the state of montana this little area on
the corner here is the flatbed
reservation so it's actually a fairly
large chunk of land the the water rights
that we're talking about today uh really
cover the entire region of northwest
montana uh mostly west of the
continental divide but there are some
rights that were affected by the treaty
that actually on the on the east side of
continental divide
um so we're going to talk about the
history uh the the kind of way that
these water rights came about some of
the context negotiations talk a little
bit about the negotiation topics and
where they ended up um and even as i go
through the history i hope to
explain
because some of the disputed rights kind
of a lot of the questions go back to the
origins of those rights i hope to kind
of bring up some of the different
disputes in the historical context so
that and also kind of
begin to
shed light on kind of the present status
of them and and how they came up with
the negotiations based on that context
so to quickly look a little bit at the
history
the treaty of hellgate which is the
treaty that created the planted
reservation in northwest montana it's
about a million and a quarter acres was
signed on 18 in 1855 by representatives
of the us as well as the tribes that
that were partied to the treaty the
treaty gave them
gave them the rights to that land
but it also included uh an unusual um
line which has become very important um
that was not included in any of the
other treaties that the us government
negotiated with the state of montana
this line is from article 3 the
exclusive right of taking fish and all
the streams running through or boarding
said reservation is further secure to
said indians as also the right of taking
fish at all usual and accustomed places
in common with citizens of the territory
so this provision maintained that the
tribes had the rights to use water that
passed through some of the lands that
they conceded that the part that says
the right of taking fish at all usual
and accustomed places this is the basis
of what have become to be known as the
tribes off reservation water rights and
we'll talk about what those are and how
those became contentious
as was often the case with treaties of
native tribes the us government you know
violated the spirit and the letter of
the hellgate treaty within a number of
decades the kind of general history that
pertains to a lot of the you know all
the native american tribes is in 1887
the dallas act was passed which
subdivided native reservations into
individual allotments and opened
reservations to settlements by whites
uh in particular the final reservation
this kind of accelerated after the flat
head allotment act of 1904 uh provided
for the distribution and irrigation of
actually slightly you know actually a
few different sizes of allotments but
predominantly 160 acre allotments indian
households
and then the rest of those of the acres
that weren't given out um were
considered surplus um and those surplus
acres were available to to non-tribal
members and so today actually most
flathead reservation residents are not
tribal members uh and there are many
both public and private non-travel water
uses including municipal uses for
example uh polson montana which is the
the county seat of lake county which is
one of four counties in the that
enters into the platform reservation um
polson montana is the sikh county of
lake montana and it's the largest town
on the planet reservation so i think
it's just important to to recognize the
complexity of the land use
the flathead indian irrigation project
was uh a federally funded uh irrigation
system that was developed over the
course of the first uh half century
mostly in the in the 20s and 30s
and it's really a really extensive
network of irritable acres canals
laterals distribution systems pumping
stations storage reservoirs
that provides irrigation to all the land
that was described on the past slide
both native uses native users and
municipal and non-native users
particularly agricultural users on the
reservation who are not uh members of
the tribe so that's
uh all you need to know about that oh
yeah and it's important to note that
cskt operates uh a large portion of fip
of the platinum indian irrigation
project um it has since the 80s
so water rights
like many western states montana adopted
a first in time first and right doctrine
of fire appropriation um and until 1973
most rights in the state were used
rights uh which means they would
exercise when someone basically took
water for a beneficial use most of the
time they never filed those rights with
the county or the state so many rights
have no paper record you know rights
often spam multiple counties and there
were and it'd be competing claims the
same quantity of water i mean this
became increasingly complex because
rights were also kept in county
courthouses so even if a right was filed
you had to go to every county courthouse
to figure out um you know if there were
competing rights so in 1972 when montana
adopted a new state constitution
recognizing existing water rights it
also called upon the state legislature
to quote establish a system of
centralized records for water rights and
that's the origin of the dispute is the
status of the indian rights in the
centralized record
in 1973 uh the water montana passed the
water use act um which mandated that the
department of natural resources
conservation permit new claims and
manage a record of water rights uh and
it established a system of adjudicating
pre-1970 claims this means that all new
claims had to be filed with the
department of natural resources to
conservation um and it began to create a
bureaucratic structure for looking at
all claims filed
prior or existing even if they weren't
filed prior to 1973.
in 79 uh the senate bill 76 established
the montana water court which was set up
uh initially on a 15-year term limit
although it's still around now 50 years
later and they're hoping to have all
their work done i believe the least most
recent estimate i saw was by 2028 that
even that is you know questionable
um and establish the water code to
adjudicate all priest 1973 claims uh
however
while this legislation was under
consideration both the u.s department of
the interior this and the tribes
expressed opposition um to having their
water rights adjudicated by a state
court because they argued that uh these
water bites the both the
federal water rights pertaining to
federal lands whether they're national
parks or bureau land management lands
and also the uh the native water rights
uh which were held and trust by the us
government
say that they argued that they were not
subject to state courts
and many in montana's agricultural
community also opposed the use of water
courts to determine native rights
because ranchers and others both on the
reservation off the reservation feared
that extensive tribal claims would
supersede their historical rights
because of the first in time
doctrine
in response the legislator amended the
draft legislation and established the
montana reserve water rights compact
commission which negotiates on the
state's behalf
the commission was also initially
authorized for a limited term but uh
that term has been was extended and
extended and extended we'll talk about
where it ended up
uh there are just quickly there are two
kinds of travel rights that retain there
are federally reserved rights that were
set aside by the federal government for
use by the native tribe um and these
have a priority date that's equivalent
to the date of the reservation's
creation
so in the flathead reservations 1855 and
they're governed by what's called the
winter's doctrine um which refers to the
supreme court doctrine
that said that when the u.s set aside
land for indian reservation it
implicitly reserved adequate water for
the tribes to fulfill their livelihoods
and so this is the on reservation rights
that we're talking about that are fairly
reserved
the aboriginal rights are rights that
predate a reservation um and are
explicitly recognized in the two years
chapter that create the reservation and
these rights have a different priority
date of time immemorial and
thailand memorial work means i thought
that was an interesting term you know
time extend what it means is time
extended to be on the reach of memory
record or tradition and definitely
ancient ancient beyond memory or record
so these are the off reservation rights
that were subject to that kind of the
provision in the original treaty that i
mentioned
and two things to note about this the
aboriginal rights uh you know almost by
definition because of the time
immemorial claim by definition have uh
an earlier priority date than the then
than all other claims in
all other water rights in montana
because of the tiny memorial date um and
something similar has actually occurred
although it's been more distributed with
the federally reserved rights
given that the tribe the flathead
reservation was not open to homesteading
by by not tribal members until 1909
the tribe has argued that their on
reservation rights are necessarily
superior or senior sorry to all other on
reservation rights regardless of whether
their aboriginal reserve
but this fact uh which has come to be
accepted was not accepted at the time
by many non-tribal residents of the
reservation
especially ranchers and other kind of
large irrigators as well as a number of
municipal governments and republican
state legislators who argued that
this
somehow constituted an unconstitutional
takings taking under the u.s
constitution under the montana
constitution it's not worth getting into
it but just to say that there there
wasn't agreement at the beginning that
was that
legislation that i just discussed set up
the comp the montana state compact
commission
and the compact commission is a
nine-member commission according to
four-year terms uh kind of in this
makeup and it created this really
complex process for getting a
uh agreement negotiated first there were
negotiations and then the full
commission wants to beat upon how to
vote upon the negotiations then it had
to go to the montana city legislature
who had to ratify it uh then the tribal
compact so on the left-hand column now
then had to go to the u.s congress in
congress uh both the senate in the house
had to ratify it uh the president had to
sign it the tribe then had to vote to
approve it and then and then and it then
needs a kind of pro forma approval um by
the montana water court uh who issues
the final decree entering the rights
agreed upon into
the system that the state now manages uh
according to the 1973 constitution so it
means there's a huge number of parties
who have to sign on to this um and at
every step of the way there have been
roadblocks and
issues and renegotiations as a result of
the complexity of this process and just
how many parties were apart
so there are a couple of other
contextual things that i want to bring
up because i think they're important to
kind of understanding the
contentiousness of the conversations
around the uh compact
three court cases that i'm gonna try to
pronounce it chyoti one two and three i
guess um there were three court cases
that were fought between 1996 and 2003
um and argued before the supreme court
um and actually the last one was only
only found kind of during the actual
negotiations i was on the supreme court
made it to boolean and it recognized the
distinction um between state appropriate
water rights and reserve water rights
and the ruling was that
new and amended water use permits on the
reservation had to show that their
proposed uses would not quote
unreasonably interfere with the planned
use for which water has already been
reserved and what the supreme court said
again and again um as this case was
re-fought in different forms actually
only the first one was actually called
joe d as it was fought in different
forms what they argued was that because
the state and because private non-tribal
water users
couldn't show proof that the uh that
their claims were not unusually
interfering with the planned use then
that burden could not be met and so a
new water use permit could not be issued
um and so this decision uh had a few
significant impacts it gave the tribes
the cskt a significant amount of
bargaining power because municipalities
and non-indian reservations of the on
the flat hand reservation uh couldn't
apply to the state for new or amended
beneficial use permits so long as the
tribes reserved rights remained
unquantified and
the potential negative impact of the
state
on the state of having to litigate each
of the claims separately to the travel
king separately was ramified it's also
important to note because that
non-indian permit holders were
frightened of not receiving sufficient
water for their own uses or losing their
water rights altogether
because of the possibility of the tribes
having having reserved claims and this
generated political panic among kind of
non-indian municipal and county
politicians and amongst other uh
irrigators in the region
in 1982
uh the tribes and coordination
oh in anticipation of negotiations with
the compact commission collaborated with
the u.s geological survey on an
extensive drainage by drainage
measurement program of groundwater
surface water stream flow river flow
minimum fill levels of of different
bodies of water um and so by the time
the negotiation started in 2000
the us government and the tribes were in
possession of unprecedented amount of
data about the uh the water that was up
for review i got to interview a long
time travel attorney who started his
career in the early 80s and retired last
year so his his career uh was bookended
basically by this negotiation what he
said was that fact finding was a process
of sharing data with the state to bring
the state up to speed
and
it's something that i think was
interesting about the negotiations is
that opposition
especially from legislators over the
course of negotiations was often
ignorance because
the
just the knowledge was so one-sided at
the start of negotiations
finally it's important to note that uh
the alternative to negotiations loomed
over over the over the uh negotiations
the tribes of the state uh if they did
not uh agree to a compact the two sides
would be forced to litigate each claim
separately in the water court that would
have been very costly and taken many
years
and it was a valid fierce on the part of
the non-tribal water users that they
would be at risk of losing their
state-appropriated water rights because
the tribe's
earlier priority dates
even the tribes recognized that having
to litigate their claims would be costly
and burdensome and just to give you a
sense
these are just the off reservation
claims that you see here uh the left are
97 rights that as of 2018 it changed a
little bit after that as of 2018 the
tribe was gonna rate was gonna um
maintain
um off reservation uh and these are the
rights that the tribe uh
that the state thought the tribe had uh
the ability to adjudicate if they didn't
have a compact and so
the tribe if a compact wasn't reached
the tribe would could have gone to court
and litigated upwards of 10 000
different water claims across western
montana and
as a result there was a lot of incentive
for the state to come to a settlement
that both
both quantified the tribes rights and
also protected the junior rights of
non-tribal water users so that this so
that this uh
you know didn't occur and there wasn't
decades of litigation over these rights
so in terms of kind of uh the
negotiation topics that the various
discussed um they were on reservation
rights pertaining to the irrigation
project on reservation advice pertaining
to the irrigation deliveries so this is
uh water from the irrigation project
that has historically been used by the
by non-tribal water users um and so
their right to continue to receive that
water there was a water from the
flathead system meaning the flathead
river um its tributaries uh and the
flathead lake um and there were a number
of non-consumptive rights uh
off-reservation there are there were
in-stream flow rights as well as state
law based non-irrigation rights which
i'll talk about a little more later um
actually one thing that i didn't put
here is the other thing that was
obviously a part of this was
off reservation rights claimed by
non-tribal users uh which is most you
know most rights of preservation rights
that were at risk as a result of this
were by non-tribal users somehow i
didn't put that on here um and then
there was implementation and so these
were the discussions i'm gonna put a a
kind of calendar in front of you and i
don't need you to read through all of it
um this is one first of two pages
because i really want to call your
attention to a couple of things so the
first thing is a start date the first
negotiation sessions occurred in 2000 um
but in 2001 uh the state issued and this
is after all three of those you know
chyoti one and two were done and the
chyoti iii was currently before the
supreme court and despite that the state
issued yet another on reservation permit
during negotiations uh despite multiple
rulings by the supreme court um and i
think it's important just because it it
shows to accept the level of distrust
and
and also
the level of skepticism that uh that the
tribe had about the state's uh ability
to willingness to negotiate uh forth
rightly i think it's also important that
the facilitator
who was bought in 2011 uh edward sheets
i i was told that i've been trying to
get in touch with him and i haven't been
able to but i was told that relatively
little had been decided by the time he
began working on the negotiations
but he brought order to the negotiations
and served as an unbiased party uh with
which both sides could discuss um and i
think the the impact of him as a neutral
party is really important um i think
also just the number of years that
passed between 2002 and 2005 the two
sides turned their attention entirely to
negotiate an interim agreement once they
realized how long it would take to come
to a final agreement and then because of
a number of uh whatever political
reasons they abandoned the interim
agreement when the compact failed in the
state legislature in 2013 uh because
that's what occurred the first compact
was agreed to it went to the state
legislature and failed um and much of
the opposition at the time was
republican representatives expressing
concern that the compact didn't uh
sufficiently protect non-tribal water
users and some of it was legitimate
concern although some of it appears to
have been political grandstanding
uh then the state and the tribes agreed
to limited reopening uh two years later
when this trial when the uh legislature
meets again they pass it um and then it
went to the u.s congress where it sat
for five years in different forms with
slight slight amendments occurring all
over the place until finally it passed
as a part of the covet 19 stimulus bill
in december
and just days after that um
the tribe council
passed it and now it's awaiting a
bureaucratic review that is expected to
be a simple routine
uh i was told by uh by john carter the
former staff attorney for the tribes
that one thing that helped the revised
agreement pass two years later was
extensive dialogue with a couple of key
republicans who were willing to learn
more about the agreement but whose
opposition
in 2013 faded by 2015 once they
understood the thing better so that's i
think something that uh i will return to
at the end but just the importance of
that of understanding um
so this is where they ended up um on
reservation rights were protected a
number of ways the tribes agreed to with
211 total on reservation rights really
detailed i didn't get into the detail
here in terms of how it's apportioned
for where it comes from where it goes
uh with a priority of 1855 they then
agreed to relinquish the right to call
all other on reservation rights the
state agreed to give the tribes
ownership of the uh or to the u.s
ownership and trust of the tribe of the
irrigation project uh provided that the
tribe continue to
deliver a certain quantity of water to
non-tribal water users non-troubled
irrigators who have historically used
the
uh irrigation project and that was a
really contentious part of the agreement
because a number of the non-travel users
wanted the state to retain ownership
then there were a number of
non-consumptive rights
yeah so one quote i'll skip a little bit
but one quote i want to say this is a
quote from a a big timber a rancher
named lawrence rosefield
who formed a group to help support the
2015 version of the compact the revised
version of the compact she gave this in
2015
and she said there uh
oh he gave it sorry lawrence uh there
wasn't much in the way two years ago of
an educational effort for the best or
legislators or anybody we're going to be
out invisible and just trying to spread
accurate information about the compact
and the whole process and that
two years later after the first
agreement failed that that educational
process was really important
off reservation uh the tribes retained
eight off reservation in-stream flow
rights as well as 58 additional rights
uh to be co-owned by the by the state
and the tribes um with very detailed
parameters the tribes agreed to
relinquish 97
many thousands of of claims protecting
then non-travel users across western
montana uh and that was hugely important
i i want to point out one thing which is
that the map i showed you earlier of the
off reservation claims it said on the
map that there were 97 off reservation
rights than in 2018 at the tribe were
getting but by the time the actual
agreement uh was passed by the u.s
congress that number had dropped to 58
and that occurred because senator daines
of montana
basically with the tribes uh negotiated
slight changes in order to get other
senators on board or the u.s centers on
board so it's interesting that even once
the agree the agreement had passed you
know was agreed to by the two sides even
once the state legislature had agreed to
it four years later when it was with the
u.s congress they were continuing to
negotiate over minor points
so that they could get this thing passed
once and for all and
quantify the tribes rights
implementation the tribes at the very
beginning the tribes wanted a unitary
system that they controlled on
reservation um over time they came to an
agreement for a unitary system that was
jointly controlled uh and this was
unprecedented for for the state and uh
who had never given up some management
to one of the tribes in the state and
also was a significant concession by the
tribes this joint board is currently
being set up with help from the state
commission
and the state read also to give 50
million dollars to a number of water
measurement irrigation efforts
the unitary system is is uh something
that a lot of the uh also again the
non-travel irrigators were very upset
about because they felt that they would
lose the ability
to negotiate rights uh that they
that they felt they didn't should not
have to go to the tribe for
um i'll leave it at that no
um a couple of conclusions that i want
to bring up one is that divergent
knowledge is an impediment early on
negotiations that you know a lot of
measurements should be jointly
undertaken or jointly observed i think
it's really interesting that that one of
the major
uh impediments in the first years was
simply the fact that the state didn't
have
anything close to the level of
understanding of the existing water on
the reservation that the tribes had and
that the us government had uh second
that impartial facilitators are
essential and should be utilized even
before negotiations begin um that the
first decade you know wasn't wasted a
lot somewhat stuff was decided upon but
um
by all accounts when edward sheets was
brought on things moved forward much
more smoothly in a really ordered
fashion and with a lot less chest
beating
uh and third so when politics are bound
to get in the way of an agreement's
approval um it's better to include
skeptical parties than to build wall
about negotiators i mean this is a
personal thing i think that certain
state representatives and senators as
well as some major irrigators might have
been if they had been educated on the
negotiations prior to the documents
public release it's possible i don't
know this is for certain but it's
possible that uh some of their
resistance could have been mitigated
and then again adaptive which we've
talked about before this class adaptive
governance necessitates shared control
finally i didn't know what to do with
this it's one question i've been
grappling with the past days as i've
been editing my doc my like my written
report um which is what should we
basically what should we make of the
fact that even after the cskt after the
tribes had negotiated with everybody in
good faith they had to give up
additional rights um in order to get it
passed by a u.s congress is there
another system given the complexity of
the process another system that that
could have been set up to help create a
process that that wouldn't have required
as much
legal approval or is that simply a fact
of history and we need to accept it um
and i'm just the question i'm interested
in
and with that i will
open it up for comments and questions
and i know there was a lot so thank you
all
yeah
thank you um erin for the nice
presentation so
now i i would like to ask um s9 to make
comments and feedback
uh very well done erin with your
presentation uh you really picked a very
complicated uh case study because it
involves very a lot of stakeholders uh
so as uh as it involves a lot of
stakeholders so my first question would
be how do you think that all
stakeholders came into one page um and
why do you think what do you think this
treaty
this this uh
um
uh treaty uh took so much time uh to you
know finally conclude uh because it
involved a lot of litigation uh what was
the things which were not going in the
right direction before and what was the
thing which uh happened this time to
make it in the right direction
in terms of why it took so long there
are a couple of things um when the water
commission was created the compact
commission was created in in the late
70s uh you know they had about about a
little over a dozen uh thing you know
agreements to negotiate with the federal
government and with the state's tribes
and they decide they purposefully did
all of the others and then did uh and
then did the 500 reservation one because
the latter reservation was the most
complicated and i think that actually um
that actually
wasn't a good thing i think that there
was a lot of a lot of study and
animosity um and kind of divergence that
that occurred in those in those
intervening decades in part i think
because uh
the tribes saw
what was coming out of these other
agreements and immediately began
formulating alternate things alternate
ideas because they didn't like what the
other agreements were saying and so a
lot of a lot more could have been done
uh logo could have done earlier i think
if discussions had started in the early
80s for example or the mid-80s um i
think the other things that that uh
impeded uh the timeline first is that
because partially because of that the
tribes came into the negotiations with a
lot of preconceived notions about what
the uh kind of what the final agreement
should look like and
there were a lot of news reports for
example after their first after their
first formal negotiation session of all
of these things that the tribes said
that they wanted in the final agreement
that the states immediately threw up
their hands and said absolutely not and
negotiations actually shut down for a
year at that point um and so and and so
if
if those conversations could have
started in the 80s when the tribes were
beginning their process of studying the
the water quantity the water quality and
if um if that you know the the questions
regarding the implementation could have
been ongoing i think a lot of
a lot of anger and uh you know could
have been mitigated so a part of it was
was was just uh
there was so much there was so much
confrontation going into the agreement
and very little trust and so you and and
the other thing i think that i think
took a lot the second thing i want to
say is that i think that uh the role of
the negotiator was really important
without the negotiator uh a lot of you
know
a lot of the opportunity for building
trust didn't didn't occur um and it
became uh you know they became venting
sessions the negotiations um and it
wasn't always a productive thing um
so that's the question in terms of in
terms of what went what took so long i
think negotiator helped a lot and then i
think eventually having i mean and this
is where i think the water diplomacy
framework does come to bear
significantly which is that i think once
once the two sides did have a shared
understanding of of the quantity of
water in all the different locations and
of the various of the you know various
legal arguments of the potential uses
uh once there was that shared
understanding it was a lot easier to
come to agreements because they
understood
from what
you know point they were uh they were uh
compromising from um whereas the tribes
went into it with a lot more
understanding and uh and were you know
put up a very hard wall to begin with
and so having that shared understanding
was was really important
sorry i i think i rambled on a little
bit there but i hope i got to your your
questions
so yes yes first do you have further
specific
questions yeah one more yeah
yeah you know it is related to the the
water diplomacy win-win framework uh how
do you think both parties uh
uh agreed on this you know on a win-win
site for example i i read somewhere on
the on i was doing some research on it
yesterday and i said i read that the
tribes were allocated the national bison
range which i think somehow uh was a
an attractive thing for them for
agreeing into this treaty
there's a secondary note with this
question is
uh you mentioned in one of your slides
that the number of uh non-tribes is kind
of more than the the actual tribal area
of tribal people
so
given the
the i just want to understand from you
what is the percentage of tribal people
there and non-tribal people and how do
you think that that balances or evens
out the whole treaty and things
in the montana region yeah so so just to
clarify the national bison range is on
the flathead reservation
um so uh so the
uh the tribes were giving uh the kind of
the managed rights over the management
of that range uh but it was already on
the reservation it wasn't it wasn't
something off reservation that they were
fighting over it was on reservation land
that was uh you know
uh
under the legal authority of the tribes
but managed in trust by the federal
government until until this occurred um
in terms of the sorry what was your
question about the about the kind of uh
the numbers of uh of non-tribal members
yeah i i wanted to know that uh in this
in this whole uh montana region which
we're just with in which the treaty is
uh enforced
um
the what is the percentage of the the
tribal people out there and the
non-tribal people like how much benefit
aren't we going to get the non-tribal
people
so i can't remember the population of
the tribe i don't remember right now i
believe i believe it's about 8 000
and about 60 percent of the members live
on the reservation so i believe it's
it's i don't know the tribal numbers
maybe it's five thousand i can't i can't
remember exactly right now how many
travel members live on the reservation
um uh
it's it's
a few times that uh in non-tribal
members it's not i'm not sure the exact
numbers again i'm not trying to members
of other positions but it's a few times
that the town of polson which is the
biggest town on the reservation
has a
population of about three and a half
thousand and there are many other small
towns um so those they were those rights
uh the tribes were given a you know the
this agreement quantified just to
clarify anybody to make this clear
before this agreement quantified the
tribes rights on the reservation
but
then there's still other water so that
other water then
because the triplets are quantified can
now be claimed by non-tribal users on
the reservation
but that makes sense um with regards to
the with regards to the irrigation
project the irrigation project included
a number of delivery schedules and those
delivery schedules were specifically to
provide water to
non-tribal irrigators who have
historically used that water um and
there was a lot of disagreement about
that those irrigators
many of them uh you know argue that the
amount of water they were being
allocated was insufficient and they were
going to have to move their lands um and
the state of action montana agreed to
actually
uh support them by helping to invest in
kind of you know
drip agriculture and other things um but
uh
it it it will protect it over the long
term their rights the non-tribal rights
on the reservation but
uh the one limitation is that the tribal
rights
which are quantified now have priority
i i took herself in question to refer to
proportionality
if you look at the overall benefits that
are allocated
to the federal government the state
government the tribe and
non-tribal members living on the
reservation yeah does the final
agreement
reflect
some kind of proportionality equal
proportion of gain
however measured
did everybody come out
roughly the same
relative to the
gains that they got not in terms of how
many people but just in terms of these
different categories yeah that's a good
question
i
um
i think in turn so in terms of the
number of people i really i don't know
in terms of the categories
um
the non-irrigators on the reservation
yes
uh so non-irrigators meaning not the
irrigation project users not uh the
non-irrigators definitely did
the the municipalities um were porsche
are going to have sufficient water to to
grow uh you know homeowners and
developers can build again for for both
reservation and non-reservation not
traveling non-tribal members there's a
significant amount of enough water and
now enough legal clarity that that was a
gain in itself
the the
the group um you know off reservation as
well i think that uh
a lot of the
off reservation definitely the uh
the non-tribal members donald trump of
the citizens of the state uh gained a
lot uh because the tribe event you know
gave up a lot of their claims the one
area where i think there's still
disagreement on and i don't have a i i
think that it's still very controversial
and it will be throughout implementation
is on reservation irrigators i think our
one group that's that still a number of
whom still feel like they did not um
have sufficient
they did not gain sufficient protection
um by uh as a result of the negotiations
good that's a good answer thank you yeah
um
do you have any feedback or questions
yes i i'll be very quickly first aaron
congratulations for your case very well
very well done very well
it's a complex case study
um
i just want to highlight some points
here i appreciate the historic context
that you gave from 18 to 1855 into 2000
also i learned i like to learn a lot
about the first in time you first write
that you mentioned before that 1973
and
you you mentioned that the facilitator
arrived in the
negotiation only in
but even with the facilitator took like
nine years
to reach the agreement
uh so to clarify it it took it actually
took so the secondary arrival of 2011
they reached their first agreement in
2013.
so so that was when they reached the
agreement um then as a result the uh
result of the state legislature voting
it down they renegotiated the agreement
uh for 20 in 2015
and at that point and at that point it
was just sitting in congress so the
facility so they weren't negotiating
anymore there were some minor things
that were changed
but uh and the facilitator is actually
still involved but
but it actually only took two years with
him to reach that agreement oh two years
ago
you don't have to do here because i know
gemma has to present the column the
columbia
presentation but if you can't describe
more in your in your paper
the negotiation process with the compact
commission i like a lot that's uh these
slides you put over there with the 90
members and if you can compare with the
water managed board that's only having
five members right
six members who own but only five can
vote
that's
i really appreciate congratulations
thank you i am
trying to understand the negotiation
process has been really tricky i like i
i've heard i've read and i i've heard
that there are uh that there are
transcripts of the negotiations out
there um but i've actually called i've
called around i've called like
the dnrc and and a number of other
people who are partied to them and i've
emailed people who mentioned that who
have cited them and i can't find them
i have a number i have a lot of the uh i
have a lot of the uh the what's it
called the um
topic lists the topic lists but not the
uh but not the transcripts themselves
which is disappointment
uh so any any other um question or
comments
from
flora or
gemma
okay thank you all i appreciate your
feedback
um
yeah so maybe before larry i i would
like to ask one thing um so how does um
national politics played a role um
because i learned that the comparison uh
the state
uh
legislator specifically the republican
legislator is um
was not in favor of this auto right
issue and
and there is some issue between um with
within the republican
and there are some conflicts so how
does it
how does it play a role in the
negotiation process um in this treaty
i define anybody to explain that
anybody i don't care who they are
because there's what the system is
designed to do
and there's what the system political
system actually does
and what it actually does is a function
of
who has the majority and who's in
leadership in the executive branch
and it doesn't matter what it says on
paper about what is a state's right what
is a national government's right what is
executive what is legislative doesn't
matter
it all changes every time there's a
shift in power and relationships so um
there is no way to answer
the question about what is this crazy
intergovernmental system we have
supposed to do
relative to indian rights because you
then also have the court entering we
have these three branches
and the supreme court got involved
in this case at one stage as you heard
from from aaron and you have the state
legislature
and you have the
federal government religiously the
congress but you also have the agencies
and the agencies have responsibilities
for the tribes the interior department
uh it is it is an insanely complicated
system
and uh it's very hard to know what's
going on even when it's happening
because it's not transparent
and people
make all kinds of private deals
and other issues get traded off against
the issue you're interested in and you
don't even know that that's why somebody
voted a certain way did nothing they
didn't care about the issue
but they got something from somebody
else for something else
so unraveling all of that i mean i think
aaron did a wonderful job as best you
can do of at least getting a timeline
and looking at the outcomes
but the process i mean even with the
transcript
it's
indecipherable
and everything related to native
americans in the united states
doesn't go the way
the law says it's supposed to
every treaty has been broken continues
to be broken
every promise
everything that the u.s government
promised and
committed to
none of it's been upheld
and so yeah i can point to what the
system says
and somebody can hold up a treaty and
say look here you i'm guaranteed certain
rights yeah well try to get it enforced
so uh it's the complexity of the u.s
intergovernmental system
and the extent to which it's really not
transparent what's happening
uh make it impossible to answer your
question
thanks uh so maybe for the final paper i
would like to ask but because this is
one of the treaty that is successful
recently in terms of water
treaty so maybe uh you can share
very specific lesson learned from the
negotiation process i think that would
be much more uh helpful in terms of
water diplomacy aspect i think as this
is very new
a kind of treaty that is successful and
how the process works and what are the
general uh
general uh lesson learned i think that
would be much more interesting things
i really liked the four concluding
points that you had i think those were
very um
strong
and as as long as in the text you will
give your you elaborate on them slightly
but as four
concluding points in terms of what can
be learned from this case i think
they're terrific yeah
thank you
you